[Applause]
[Music]
SNL has been functioning I believe in
pretty much exactly the same way since
1975 on Monday you meet the hosts more
and calls on you one at a time and you
say a few ideas you actually have to
write those ideas you're mainly just
trying to make everybody laugh sort of a
colossal waste of time creatively but a
nice diplomatic thing to sort of say to
the host like don't worry we're all
pretty funny you're gonna be okay and
not humiliate yourself and then you
write pretty much until Wednesday
morning right all day Tuesday and all
night Tuesday
and at Wednesday there's a big table
read where the cast and the host read
all the pieces out loud sometimes the
list would be like 50 sketches it takes
like four or five hours this
read-through the producer is Lauren and
the host and the head writers they go
back into a room and they pick like the
10 or 12 best ones the ones that made
everybody laugh the most it's pretty
meritocratic I mean if something if
something works it's in definitely all
the time and it doesn't matter if it was
written by a first-year writer whose
main people are forgetting the sketch
goes into the pile and Thursday you
rewrite these sketches as a group trying
to punch them up and improve them and
Friday and Saturday you're rehearsing
and building sets and building props and
designing costumes and then at 8 p.m. on
Saturday there's a full dress rehearsal
it's two hours long lauren watches the
sketches and a little monitor you sit
next to him he tells you his notes the
great thing about working for Lauren is
that it gives you full creative freedom
he lets you try whatever you want there
aren't heavy notes but when there is a
note you trust it because it's backed by
you know decades and decades of mastery
of comedy then you go into they go into
another little room and they cut another
half an hour out of the show based on
which sketches perform the worst in
front of the audience so it's it can be
really stressful because you really work
hard on your sketches but there's
multiple times at which they could just
be cut completely out of the show like
in sports you know if you
break out use have to kind of try to
forget it because next week you have
another show to do a lot of people
assume that SNL is like a really
competitive socially toxic environment
that it was like backstabbing and
rivalries and feuds it's really not true
and in my experience it was one of the
most friendly groups I've ever seen
people were incredibly generous to one
of the other helping each other out all
the time for zero credit people like
Seth Meyers and Colin Jost to or you
know senior writers were extremely
generous with their time explaining to
me stuff which in hindsight was
unbelievably basic like I would do
things sometimes in my in my sketches
where like a character would be like
alright here we are at the dentist's
office you know because I was like we
need to some exposition about where they
are and they were like you know you
could just like show a dentist office oh
wow that's really amazing and I saw that
everywhere I went every year when the
new writers came in because mostly
people have never written for television
before stand-up comedians or people who
have written funny articles for
magazines or he hires like playwrights
or people who've done like some web
videos he almost never hires somebody
whose written for another actual actual
television show so you have all these
novices coming in the more experienced
writers are so nice and they they really
they really teach them and so I I'm
super grateful for the experience
because it was fun but also I learned
almost everything I know at that show